bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors que se passe-t-il
la cafétéria de la pitié salpêtrière
avez vous des informations de nouveau
c'est une opération médiatique de la
direction de l'assistance publique de
martin hirsch avec le directeur médical
de crise ces particules en scandale
parce qu'il existe des locaux
disponibles savez là je sors de garde je
viens de la seine saint denis
il y à un hôpital qui s'appelle
l'hôpital jean verdier dans lequel il y
à une réanimation qui à moitié vide dans
lequel il ya des locaux dont des anciens
locaux qui accueillait des vires
animation qui peuvent être utilisés
plutôt que de vouloir faire des travaux
dans un self et organisait le self sous
les tentes dans les jardins de l'hôpital
on est face à une attitude irresponsable
de la direction d'assistance publique
qui ne veut pas accepter que on peut
rouvrir des lits dans les hôpitaux qui
sont en train de fermer parce que ils
veulent poursuivre la fermeture de ces
hôpitaux et rien n'a été fait depuis le
printemps dernier pour ouvrir des lits
de réanimation et là dans l'urgence
alors on fait les opérations médiatiques
qui mobilise beaucoup de moyens et le
personnel c'est de l'incurie la plus
totale et celle met vraiment en colère
alors vous parlez de l'hôpital
jean-verdier à bondy n'ya également
l'hôpital hôtel dieu de paris où il y
aurait des lignes disponibles selon des
médecins sur place vous venez de nous le
confirmer pourquoi alors ce refus de ne
pas les utiliser par les autorités parce
que ces autorités sont responsables de
la fermeture des hôpitaux qu'ils veulent
poursuivre sa vessie au goût des liens
l'hôtel dieu
il ya et bien cela prouvera que cet
hôpital doit ne doit pas fermer
or là on poursuit l'opération
immobilière avec sur la partie de
l'hôtel dieu qui est face à notre dame
l'ouverture d'un centre commercial et la
restaurants étoilés et à jean verdier
c'est aussi un programme de fermeture de
l'hôpital
et si il accepte aujourd'hui de rouvrir
des vies dans ces hôpitaux et bien ce
serait pour eux une honte parce qu' il
faudrait qu'ils axent qu'ils acceptent
de reconnaître qu' il faut arrêter ces
opérations de restructuration et des
fermetures de lits je rappelle que
monsieur marc taïeb directeur général de
l'assistance publique
plutôt que de se préoccuper louverné
ville réanimation ces dernières semaines
s'est promené dans la seine saint denis
au nord de paris pour aller promouvoir
le fameux hôpital mort qui va se
traduire par la fermeture de deux
hôpitaux bichat et beaujon et la
fermeture de quasiment 4 100 lits voilà
donc ce sont des pousses pilates et qui
essayent de cacher leur incurie avec des
opérations médiatiques tron va monter un
hôpital de campagne dans un salon mais
c'est du n'importe quoi est ce que nous
sommes un pays du tiers monde ou est ce
que nous sommes à paris dans une des
premières métropoles mondiales
vous savez on avait réclamé aussi il ya
quelques mois que l'hôpital du val de
grâce qui a été fermée récemment soit un
hôpital qui soit programmé pour pouvoir
ouvrir des livres quel besoin
aujourd'hui
il héberge des militaires dans des
chambres l'hôpital les militaires de
l'opération vigipirate
voilà donc les rivières moment donné il
faut dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont c'est un véritable stand est ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui
alors on nous dit qu'il ya des problèmes
de lits dans les hôpitaux 1
mais l'exécutif conditions rajoute délit
mais qu'on n'a pas de rani matters ça ne
sert pas à grand chose alors on en
revient à cette idée de l'ap-hp une
section une session nocturne d'une
formation express de deux jours pour
former des soignants à la réanimation
elles sont une véritable solution selon
vous attendent et ils se foutent de nous
vous savez nous avons ouvert douze mille
lits de réanimation printemps dernier du
personnel avaient commencé à être formés
ce que nous avions proposé c'était de ne
pas fermer ces lits de réanimation mais
ne poursuit la formation de ses
personnels
le personnel pour être performant
réanimation sépare en deux jours c'est
en deux à trois mois
c'est lire animation était fermé au mois
de mai juin hélas aujourd'hui on nous
dit qu'on va former du personnel en deux
jours mais attendez de keith poston rien
n'a été préparé et là dans l'urgence eh
bien on fait les opérations médiatiques
en bouillie on va former les personnels
la nuit on va ouvrir dans un self des
lits de réanimation mais de qui se moque
t'on je m'excuse d'être un petit peu
virulent mais il va falloir qu'à l'issue
de cette crise les gens qui ont pris ses
responsabilités de fermer les livres
animation qui avait ouvert au printemps
dernier ne veut pas voir former le
personnel
l'été dernier où nous étions dans une
période où on pouvait être formé du
personnel beaucoup
calme et qui aujourd'hui dans
l'affolement des biens-fonds vibrionne
et font des opérations médiatiques pour
montrer que finalement ils sont sur le
terrain non ils n'ont pas été sur le
terrain ils n'ont rien fait pour
préparer
effectivement ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et le ministre est un des
premiers responsables parce qu'on va
être juillet dernier monsieur
verrons-nous lisette n'y a pas de
problème nous pouvons armée 2010 des
animations
mais ils sont où ces douze mille lits de
réanimation alors si on parle du
principe que l'exécutif a failli que des
mauvais choix ont été faits depuis le
début de cette crise sanitaire pour
quelle raison parce que cet exécutif a
mal été conseiller parce qu'il n'a pas
vraiment conscience de la réalité
pourquoi
non c'est pas parce qu'il a mal été
conseillé c'est parce que il reste dans
sa stratégie de réduction des moyens de
l'hôpital public parce que c'est une
politique libérale
écoutez ça fait 30 ans qu'on nous
explique on l'a trop lui que l'hôpital
coûte trop cher qu'il faut diminuer les
effectifs qui pour fermer des lits
combat tout gérer avec de l'ambulatoire
que quand les malades
effectivement sont mis dehors de
l'hôpital on va les héberger dans cet
hôtel hospitalier c'est cette logique
libérale de le fonctionnement de
l'hôpital entreprise à plus tendue qui
aujourd'hui est un échec et ils ne
veulent pas le reconnaître et ça
effectivement je peux vous dire que le
mouvement de l'hôpital pendant un an
avant la crise était sur ses
revendications le mouvement des gilets
jaunes la pause et aussi les mêmes
problèmes derrière un moment donné soit
ce gouvernement change de politique soit
il va falloir le balayer et voilà il
arrive un moment donné c'est pas
possible qu'on poursuit cette politique
libérale qui se aujourd'hui il faut
savoir que aucun des projets de
restructurations hospitalières qui
prévoit des fermetures de lits dans les
mois et dans les années qui viennent ne
sont supprimés
que ce soit l'hôpital nord à paris
l'hôpital de saclay la rénovation du chu
de nantes de nancy du chr d'orléans les
hôpitaux de drôme nord là en ce moment
suppriment des emplois et ferme des
livres écouter c'est une duplicité de la
part des gens qui nous gouvernent
département scandaleuse
christophe prudhomme merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions rappelle vous
êtes porte parole de médecins
urgentistes de france merci à vous et à
vous